هجوم بالمسيرات الانتحاريه استهدف العاصمه
الاوكرانيه هو الاوسع من نوعه منذ بدايه
الحرب في يومها الوطني هكذا وصف رئيس
الاداره العسكريه للعاصمه الاوكرانيه هذا
الهجوم الكبير الذي ادى الى اضرار واسعه
في عدد من الاحياء والمنشات والمنازل التي
وجهت نحوها المسيرات الانتحاريه تقول
الاداره العسكريه ان اكثر من اربعين مسيره
اسقطت في سماء العاصمه الاوكرانيه ادى
حطامها الى عدد من الاضرار في عدد من
المنشات فيما نشاهد هذا الحجم الكبير من
الاضرار الذي تعرضت له هذه المنشاه على
اطراف العاصمه الاوكرانيه والتي تبلغ
مساحتها الفا متر مربع ادت الى انفجارات
كبيره والى حرائق من بين عدد من
الانفجارات والحرائق التي دوت في عدد من
احياء العاصمه الاوكرانيه تحديدا في
المنطقه الجنوبيه والمنطقه الشرقيه
للعاصمه هذا الهجوم الليلي كان هجوما امتد
لاكثر من خمس ساعات
متواصله خلال الليل
واستطاعت دفاعات الجويه ان تتعامل مع عدد
من الاهداف في سماء العاصمه الا ان الخطر
مازال متواصل باتجاه العاصمه الاوكرانيه
وهو ما تحذر منه السلطات هنا حسن مسعود
الجزيره كيف